Okay.
Let's see.
We've got so many people holding maybe more
than ever before.
Let's try the seven oh five area code.
Who's calling today from seven oh five and
just as input.
Whoa.
Hold on a second.
Hello.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Hi, I'm calling from Ontario, Canada actually.
Okay.
Larry, your connection is, is one of the worst.
We've had a, you're not talking into the phone
through like a crinkled piece of paper, are
you?
No, no, I was just, I'm moving around.
Is it better now?
It's, it's marginally better.
What's your question?
I was just wondering like, I'm Canadian.
I was wondering why it seems that Americans
think that if you get a single payer healthcare
system that your insurance through your employer
would go away.
We have it here in Canada.
Um, it covers a vast majority of things that
don't get covered by our single payer system.
Well, I don't think everybody does think that.
I mean, yeah, listen, so there have been questions
asked as does private insurance get made illegal
if you get single payer or something like
that.
And most people say no, allow it to exist.
That could cover a optional procedures.
It could cover a cosmetic procedures, it could
cover procedures at different facilities than
maybe the single payer system.
And sorry to cut you off there.
Things like dental and, uh, I, I wear like
for going to see an optometrist and things
like that.
Right.
That's exactly right.
So it's just, I don't know, I just seems to
be, I guess maybe it's, uh, they're, I just
trying to draw me on the argument that people
would lose insurance that they have through
their employer.
Well, Louis Louis versus not need are two
different things and there's certainly no
question that many employers would simply
stop even offering to subsidize some kind
of for profit plan if instead there was some
kind of single payer plan available that that's
all true.
But I think the, the point is private insurance,
if you don't outlaw it will still exist and
it will still be available.
That might cost more at night, might not make
sense to pay for it, but, uh, it's still something
that would exist,
I guess.
That makes sense.
Um, maybe legislators should look at ways
of having it so that it can exist to cover
those things that wouldn't be, would be outside
of this.
Yeah, you don't even need to look at it.
I mean, it exists and as long as you don't
outlaw private insurance, it'll, it'll continue
to exist.
Listen, I'm going to let you go because the
connection is just, I don't know what it sounds
like a, I don't even know what it sounds like,
but I appreciate the phone call and we'll,
we'll continue to inform people on that issue.